welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
boss I'm here with Jessica Clements and
this is a breakdown of the trailer for
the Marvels the Captain Marvel sequel
team up film coming this November chess
what an awesome trailer this was I'm
obsessed with this trailer also I am a
huge Beastie Boys fan so I was so
excited do you know how hard it is to
use the rights of Beastie Boys songs you
can only use sabotage and only so many
times so I'm so happy they got
Intergalactic it's so good I love
Perfect part of this trailer so we're
gonna break down all the Easter eggs the
details you missed in this trailer the
timeline of all these characters
everything you need to know from Miss
Marvel from One Division from all of it
we got you covered let's get started
what the hell are you doing
entering the jump Point perimeter
I'm gonna get you some readings so the
trailer opens on a new space station
called the saber s-a-b-e-r not the the
Lost Dunder Mifflin zebra but saber uh
this is based on the peak in Marvel
Comics it's a space station for sword
and Earth's orbit to protect Earth from
cosmic and extraterrestrial threats I
wonder if Saber might stand for
something like Security Agency border
and extraterrestrial response I don't
know it's gonna be some version of that
I'm guessing sword launched this after
this Celestial erishim showed up in
eternals you know scared the hell out of
everyone and when teammate popped out of
the Indian Ocean but you know looking at
the globe there it doesn't look like
there's any sign of him from space
because you know that little
Stratosphere popper definitely would
show up if they were facing that side of
the planet now the coordinates are
actually in military time so 3 23 and 12
seconds in Earth establishes it as
Earth's eastern time in the array of
numbers and letters are actually Earth's
coordinates that were referenced in
Captain Marvel when this is called Terra
and Monica Rambo she's perfect she's
everything I'm kind of dressed like her
I look like her we're the same person
whatever Monica Rambo is the daughter of
Maria Rambo if you guys remember member
the call sign Photon Carol danvers's
pilot friend in the 2019 Captain Marvel
film in one division though adult Monica
played by Tiana Parrott returned from
the blip to find Maria had died from
cancer Monica returned a sword where her
mom was the former director and dealt
with Wanda maximoff's Westview crisis
that resulted in her getting radiated by
The Cosmic radiation of Wanda's hex
though it was implied that Monica had
already been irradiated and she had some
bitterness with Carol One Division ended
with Monica getting recruited by a
scroll to join Nick Fury who when we
last saw him was hanging out with the
Scrolls on a different space station in
the post-credits scene of Spider-Man far
from home we'll see how all of this ties
in with the scroll spearsity of the
secret Invasion yeah that is coming
sooner before this uh the Marvel's film
so there's a lot to learn there Nick
Fury seems to be overseeing Monica's
astronaut program on saber as Monica
investigates this nearby jump point if
you look closely you can see the
hexagonal Wormhole grid this is the untn
universal neural teleportation Network
that's the mcu's galactic transportation
system is created by James Gunn for
Guardians Volume 2 and later shown in
Captain Marvel an Avengers end game and
Guardians holiday special Guardians
volume 3 coming the trailer uses the
Beastie Boys Intergalactic it's a
perfect track for the cosmic crisis
these women find themselves in but in
this opening section all we really hear
of it are these detached simply yeah
these shrieks stick listen
foreign
I think it works as kind of a warning
siren or maybe like a Yelp that
punctuates each time these four women
get thrown out of place as a result of
their entanglement it's so funny yeah
I love it I love it I love it oh God I
love it okay one more clip
[Applause]
[Music]
Monica floats up to the barrier of the
hexagonal Wormhole the scale is insane
but you can see the massive Bend of the
corner of the hexagon and its other side
it's blue and glitching a bit like it's
malfunctioning also you know she's doing
this Rogue because a Nick Fury is
concerned that she's doing this and B
she's not attached to the space station
does the jump Point have a gravitational
pull or did she just push off of
something regardless as Monica gets
closer to the jump perimeter her
connection with Nick begins to static
eventually losing each other altogether
all this to say that we can lose
communication easily When approaching
the untn which matters more now than
ever because we're getting into secret
Invasion which deals with the grounded
events and Cosmic ones so we're just
gonna be losing touch with people in
space all the time this is our our Brave
New World now what's really going on
here well in the Miss Marvel series
Kamala Khan finds this bangle that
belonged to her great grandmother who is
a being from the nor Dimension nor
meaning light and that was found in a
cave on Earth with markings of the ten
Rings the Bengal was actually on a
shriveled blue hand blue often being the
color of many of the cree and we
wondered at that time of the Bengals and
thus the 10 Rings could come from
ancient Greek technology and perhaps the
beacon in the tin ring from the shangshi
post credit scene was summoning these
Creed Earth right now to claim these
relics and in this film's trailer a
second Bengal appears on the arm of the
villain zowie Ashton who's definitely
played a Cree accuser believed to be the
cree General from the comics named Dar
Ben and you may remember Ronan the
Accuser from guardians volume 1 and
Captain Marvel he was a member of this
dynasty of extremist zealots within the
cree Empire called accusers Ronan died
in Guardians volume 1 and now it appears
that Zoe Ashton is playing his successor
She carries a cosme rod just like the
one Roman had these are Universal
Weapons that all the accusers carry but
also miss Marvel's Kamala Khan used the
bangle to create riffs in space time a
gate to the nor Dimension AKA The Veil
as well as a portal back in time to save
her own grandmother so these riffs in
space time may have caused a disturbance
to the cosmic radiation that fuels the
untn there's so many theories as Monica
approaches the jump Point her space suit
sleeve begins to phase shift into a new
wardrobe sleeve with her bare band
showing that the quantum entanglement
has just begun yeah and the close-up of
her hand shows vibrant teal and fuchsia
Cosmic radiation coursing through her
fingers looking exactly like Monica in
her spacing pushing through Wanda's hex
wall in One Division episode 7. now we
have joked before about the idea of
every hexagon in the mc2 being connected
but Jess aren't these connected right no
like they are two hexes fueled by neural
Cosmic radiation that distort space time
I mean it doesn't sound that crazy it
doesn't it just seems like between Wanda
sex and one Division and Monica pushing
through it and what Kamala did with the
Bengal and Ms Marvel all of these have
overloaded Cosmic radiation throughout
the MCU to break the untn right here and
resulting in these three individuals
linked to this Cosmic radiation becoming
entangled like this handcuffed together
in a Freaky Friday scenario Kamala has
swapped into Monica's Place Monica swaps
into Carol's place and Carol has swapped
into kamala's place in her bedroom and
that Miss Marvel post credit scene that
we learned that Nia DeCosta also shot
and a little Easter egg back in the
saber here on Nick Fury's desk is the
pager that Carol Danvers gave him a
Captain Marvel that he used to summon
her in the infinity War post credit
scene we love how kamala's clear really
too short to fit into this astronaut
suit and she reaches up her head into
the helmet to see Nick Fury who to her
is a celebrity which
people know who he is this is a bit
surprising okay because Fury is a more
secretive figure but maybe he came up in
Scott Link's podcast or his Memoir
either way Kamala is a huge Avengers
super fan so she would know who he is
her immediate exception is that this is
all a test to join the Avengers she's
been waiting for the call and also a fun
detail kamala's enthusiastic tapped on
the window glass
is what sends her back out to space due
to Newton's third law Monica lands were
presumably Carol Danvers recently was at
the moment of the switch she lands on
the lunar surface through what looks
like a broken purple hexagonal Wormhole
one permanently stuck open yeah and
Monica hits his surface wearing a dark
uniform with red or orange lining to it
I'm not sure what this is or if or why
Carol would be wearing it in the
situation she was pulled from but Monica
seems to still have this plastic cord
Loop hanging from her hip looking a lot
like that cord that was on the side of
the saber spacesuit but either way she
gets rushed by these soldiers and Tall
helmets we're not with the Cheryl any of
these people can breathe on a moon with
no atmosphere but either way their
helmets look like the tall angled ones
worn by the cree soldiers in Captain
Marvel and those Warriors Miss minutes
animated TVA video in Loki episode one
because really could have been Cree
soldiers in that past War Monica
teleports away but the trailer editing
makes it look like it's synced with
Carol's arrival in kamala's room but we
think that's deceptive because many of
the swaps in this trailer actually seem
to be pulling from different moments in
different exchanges yes and also Carol
appears in kamala's room and it's the
exact same post-credit scene we saw at
the finale for Miss Marvel but we we do
get some different angles of kamal's
room though yes we got a ton of Captain
Marvel merch we see Einstein's theory of
relativity exploring the force of
gravity in space and time which is a
direct shout out to this entire film
they're all in space we see her sloth
for her personal YouTube channel sloth
baby Productions we know that Kamala
attended Avenger con and Miss Marvel she
clearly loves conventions just like me
she has different badges for different
cons one is Cape Cod that's the one in
the front the yellow badge in the back
resembles the Jersey con poster at the
top we have a Captain America shield
lanyard and Iron Man yellow lanyard
she's just a little nerd she's just a
little nerd like the rest of us come
back on the channel come back on the
channel this section opens with the
opening line of the Beastie Boys
Intergalactic well now don't you tell me
to smile which is
[Laughter]
don't ever interrupt me like that
you don't smile at you I'm so sorry
which ties into this which is really
just perfect for three female
superheroes learning to put their
frustrations aside and just get the job
done you guys can do it Intergalactic is
the perfect song for this trailer not
just for the obvious title but the
Beastie Boys are a trio who all wrap in
sync with each other and all shout the
final rhyming word together at the same
exact time they sound angry but they're
also just having a blast and they're
very fun there are improv games that use
this song to teach performers to be
quick on their feet and set each other
up we do it all the time me and Eric
similarly this Trio of women have to
figure out how to do this exact same
thing to share the light yes and we see
the Marvel Studios title card the one
updated for phase four includes Jane
Foster from Thor 11 Thunder She-Hulk
Moon Knight Wanda move to the island of
the r as was the case for one division
but instead of Marvel Studios it's
reversed Studios Marvel it only corrects
when the purple Cosmic radiation
teleports into space almost as if it's
saying things are only right when we go
intergalactic I'm sorry I hate myself
now we see Manhattan from the
perspective of Kamala Khan's home
neighborhood of Jersey City and you know
I could be wrong here but towards the
left behind and to the left of the
Empire State Building that might might
be Avengers Tower it's been unless I've
been in New York I don't know the
skyline exactly the New Yorkers are
going to call me out you always do that
so it might not be Avengers Tower but
either way Marvel seems to have stopped
bothering putting Avengers Tower in
their Skyline a lot of these things if
they do include it in this movie it
could be a good place to replace that a
with q-e-n-g as was the case on that
pruned variant of the Tower and the TBA
boy to establish the new owner of the
tower as the Kang variant of Mr Griffin
who we were pretty sure showed up in the
quantumania post credit scene and the
cotton home front door opens to the full
family returning from the Miss Marvel
series moan Kapur as Yusuf Khan Zenobia
as muniba Khan and Sagar Sheikh as
kamala's brother Amir there are also two
men gagged and chained up in their
living room
and Monica you'll see is wearing that
white saber Cadet jacket and the others
wearing the saber space station which
seems to be a seven stone for the outfit
she'll be suiting up into later it's
diagonal lines from the shoulders
reflect photon's Limitless suit design
and by the way we assume that she'll go
by Photon and not Spectrum as Photon was
her mother's call sign and in Miss
Marvel Kamala and Bruno complete her
cosplay with in their words a capital P
Photon gloves that light up oh damn
that's how she's gonna get her name is
from Kamala uh and her mom I love this I
love this keep it going I'm a big fan of
being my best self and Beyond failing my
brain with fun things to think about
dogs wearing pants hamsters and top hats
you know the usual stuff I also like to
take care of my body and if you like
taking care of your body You're Gonna
Want to fully tune in because we are
going to have one of the best offers
we've ever given on this channel thanks
to geology geology is an 18-time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
geology creates simple and effective
skincare and Hair Care routines
customized just for you with ingredients
that are proven to work their products
are built around just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades just take a quick 30 second
diagnostic quiz and geology will create
a simple and effective skin care or hair
care routine customized just for you
with ingredients that are dermatologist
tested proven to work and personalized
to your needs geology has got you
covered no matter how you're looking to
up your personal care game but right now
they are offering a special offer for a
skincare sampler pack which is great
because their skin care stuff rules
geology's line of skin care products can
help you fight acne reduce oil-ness
prevent wrinkles and combat dark or
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging
personally I'm a fan of their vitamin C
plus e fioric acid serum but I use
everything else geology has co-wash for
your hair body wash for your body and
deodorant for your odors whatever you
need gelji has you covered there's never
been a better time to try geology than
right now for a limited time to use code
new Rockstar's 100 to get 100 off your
personalized 30 day skincare sample set
all you have to do is cover the 495 for
shipping this is hands down the best
deal that is out there and on top of
that new Rockstar's fans get an
exclusive bonus offer up to 50 off on
additional skin hair and body product of
your choice when you add it to your
trial click the link in the description
or go to
geolog.i.e rockstars 100 to get started
Kamala thinks this is all about her
Avengers initiation and her first
instinct is to ask did I get in she
doesn't yet know that being an Avenger
isn't just a status it's a crappy
responsibility that falls in one's lap
as a result of a crisis on to the next
section okay so our powers are entangled
I can manipulate light energy and you I
could totally show you
oh yeah
oh I'm not again
hi where's our daughter wherever you
were Monica explains to the Khan family
what's going on in their Rec living room
it looks like the two tied up men are
gone and Kamala has now changed into a
flannel with a shirt showing kept in a
Marvel comic book covers the t-shirt is
showcasing Captain Marvel issue number
18 which me Jessica Clemens could not
find that matches the same cover but
issue number 18 of 2019's issue of
Captain Marvel she wields the cosme rod
which we may see later during the fight
scene at the end of the trailer so I
think that's just a reference to that
and Kamala holds a digital dossier of
herself with the same pile photo of
actress Iman villani that went around
when she was announced as kabala Cod
they put that in there also you'll
notice there's a rolling pin in the
rubble on the floor there make you just
wonder if those Cree soldiers could have
been brought down in part by maniva just
clubbing them with it so Monica Rambo's
eyes glow purple now which is
interesting because in one division
episode 7 we saw that they were glowing
blue and here she phase shifts so that
the cree soldier who has apparently
broken loose in all of this madness
cannot jabber he just Jabs through her
and we saw her do this in one division
when she absorbed those bullets that
Hayward shot at the boys now sitting at
Fury and Monica's feet you'll notice in
the scene is goose the flirkin returning
from the 2019 Captain Marvel film this
is a cat-like alien that can devour huge
things and store them inside of its body
via a pocket reality now Goose was named
after Maverick's wingman and Top Gun it
was changed from the plurkin's name of
the comics which was chewy Kamala
demonstrates her powers she can cast
hard light to him big in parts of her
body create Shields and platforms for
her to Lily Pat across she can do this
in part because of the bangle but also
thanks to her great grandmother coming
from the Nord Dimension and the finale
of Miss Marvel established her as a
mutant so she has a million Powers this
was a retcon of the kamala's status as
an inhuman in the comics but the comics
Creator G Willow Wilson confirmed that
she originally intended on making Kamala
mutant but Marvel Comics in the early
2010s didn't want to launch moving
characters since Fox then had the film
rights of the X-Men as it goes
Kamala swaps with Carol who is
mid-flight Carol is frustrated because
you never know when it's gonna happen
but this is in a way the best thing for
her character because otherwise she'd be
powerful enough to do anything by
herself this forces her to learn how to
cooperate and work in a trio kind of
like the three Peters did in no way home
all right let's move on to the next part
get up
okay so the editing in here makes it
seem like Kamala went straight from the
living room to this quarter of the ship
but now notice she's wearing her Miss
Marvel suit and goose is with her which
doesn't really make sense because Goose
isn't entangled so I think this is
another example of the trailer's tricky
editing since Carol was flying Kamala
actually swapped into the in the middle
of the air falling to her death which we
see later in the trailer when Monica
swoops in to save her so this scene
comes through in a different part of the
film in Goose devours two Cree soldiers
and iman's reaction is so good
and yeah another Soldier runs up behind
them but we gotta assume goose is gonna
eat him too no no no no no okay here we
go Intergalactic a ship buzzes past an
asteroid belt or a ring of his green
colored planet and Carol and Monica look
completely comfortable but Kamala
totally freaked now we assume this is
Carol's ship even though she wouldn't
need one you would think but she
actually does we'll talk about why later
in the trailer but notice this I love
this Monica is wearing the nine inch
nail shirt the nin shirt that Cara wore
in 1995 in the previous movie it's kind
of like a Ragnarok where Thor and banner
were on the quinjet and banner wore
Tony's clothes and they are moving on to
this new location of the MCU they
actually film this in tropea Italy on
the east coast of the tyranian sea
finally the MCU has Crossover with White
Lotus and we are here for it
but the town doesn't always look like
this they've added via VFX these landing
pads and a curved pointed building on
the right which kind of feels like Cree
architecture maybe another part of
challah or one of their colonies but
since Park SEO yoon's character has been
named to Prince Yan this could be aladna
a planet visited only briefly in Captain
Marvel number nine from 2014. this
planet's pretty interesting because
every person speaks in Rhymes yeah those
Beast boys are coming back this time
smile
and what's interesting here
Prince John becomes kids Planet men have
no freedom of choice on this planet and
women choose their mates
I gotta go
we get our first shot of Monica and her
black and white classic Photon suit and
she looks great unlike the star Ward on
Maria Rambo's Captain Marvel suit in the
838 Universe Monica's emblem is more of
a shooting star or Comet and part of the
saber station Kabbalah uses her nor
light to defend against an attacking
Cree Soldier while Nick Fury scrambles
for cover though the scenes are hard to
follow in the trailer Kamala was in her
suit when she swapped with Monica so
this scene could be right after she just
met Nick Fury immediately the ship was
under attack it could be that the cree
has the signal to the Bengal there's a
vibrant dance in the streets of this new
planet and I am going to be there soon
Carol tries to mask herself under some
insane jellyfish headgear while Monica
and Kamala walk behind her and The Wider
overhead shot Carol has lost the hat but
Kamal is just letting loose baby
koalas just letting loose baby she's
there to join in not on the dance just
like shiv at Kendall's 40. now if this
is aladna we could be looking at a
courtship ritual where women roam around
to take their picks at the available men
which could explain why Kamala Has No
Reservations about going full out like
this now back on the space station Fury
shout out to the other saber Cadets
Shields up likely prepping for the cree
attack that they're coming under but
there is some word play here because
sword is in essence what happens when
Shield goes up I hate myself but
cheering me up is a whole litter of
flirkin running down the stairs and we
know it's saber because of those six
beam windows and the central Spire
structure in the distant background but
think about it a whole Legion aflorgan
is really all you need to defend a
planet and then in aladna Ashton's
character marches in with her cosme Rod
again just like the one Ronin had but
these are considered sacred Universal
Weapons that all create accusers wield
and behind her interestingly is another
Cree accuser Zealot with headgear very
similar to ronin's but she looks like a
priestess so it seems like their mission
will be to follow and ronan's footsteps
to cleanse to purify what they believe
or the cree Empire but perhaps under a
matriarchal power hierarchy and on to
the final part
our three Marvels team up Monica out
front Cara on the left and what looks
like a new suit carrying a staff hard to
tell but Carol may be using Ashton's
cosme rod in this three-on-one fight
scene or a broken version of it the
three now confidently use that
entanglement to their advantage Ashton's
character blast Kamala with her bangle
Kamala raises her Shield but it
disintegrates as she swaps into a marble
who doesn't have the power Monica who
uses her Photon powers to blast Ashton
Ashton blocks the blast and Kabbalah now
behind her hits her with the ambition
fist bam bigger and bigot smile
now a question he might have is why
doesn't Carol just go binary and in this
well maybe her entanglement leaves her
power down in this movie which is why
she would need to manually pilot a ship
instead of flying around independently
in space this would kind of be the
classic second movie in the superhero
Trilogy structure at least the best of
them like Remy Spiderman 2 or Captain
America Winter Soldier where the hero
loses their powers or their status a bit
and gets forced out of a comfort zone
and it forces them to prove to us what
heroism really looks like and after
Carol and Monica insists that they are
in a team the final title card suggests
otherwise combining all three of their
Insignia Monica's emblem of the a
kamala's swish of the S and the text of
Marvel with the same lens flare from the
2019 Captain Marvel title mmm this
trailer was fun I'm excited about this
movie I also just realized yeah maybe
she's not uh she's flying the ship
because she keeps getting traded in the
air with someone that can't fly with
Kabbalah so it's like suffocating yeah
just in case we'll just appear in the
ship again we won't appear in the middle
of space we will all stay in an
oxygenated
container
We're Not Gonna risk it just immediately
their heads pop when they go out to
space
I wonder I that scene has to happen and
they're probably very they're like look
you're not gonna die in space on us
that's insane all right I think that's
why Kamala Khan so freaked out in that
chair like please don't swap please
don't swap no one use their powers no
one move nobody move so thank you for
watching this be sure to subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive if you
watch my live stream discussion about
this trailer where I didn't catch a lot
of this stuff because I was very tired
you could support our growing Network by
grabbing something from our merch store
nerd right shop I got something from the
deep down collection but we got a ton of
great stuff especially for the Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 movie coming out oh
yeah that does he know me mug I think my
favorite thing you can get on the shop
um subscribe to new Rockstar on YouTube
on all social platforms you can follow
us on social media at Lulu underscore
Clemens thank you for watching and don't
tell me don't
I'm leaving
[Music]